la séance est reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi visant à renforcer
la prévention et la lutte contre
l'incendie l'intensification et
l'extension du risque incendie présentée
par Monsieur jean-bachi Madame Catherine
Loisier Monsieur Pascal Martin et
Monsieur Olivier Riemann c'est une
demande de la Commission de la
l'aménagement du territoire et
développement durable et de la
commission des affaires économiques la
procédure accélérée a été engagée sur ce
texte dans la discussion générale la
parole est d'abord à Monsieur Bacci
auteur de la proposition de loi un
premier auteur
[Applaudissements]
je suis le président madame la ministre
de mini que Faure Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues je
souhaite redire mon émotion sincère de
présenter le texte devant notre
assemblée
en tant que premier co-auteur de cette
proposition de loi est président de la
commission spéciale chargée de son
examen j'ai proposé début 2022 au
président Longeot une mission de
contrôle sur les feux de forêt à la
suite du forum de Gonfaron dans le Var
qui a coûté la vie à deux personnes et
détruit 8000 hectares dans la plaine des
morts en août 2021
[Musique]
cette évolution du risque a évidemment
jeté une lumière particulière sur nos
travaux dès lors empreint d'une gravité
et d'une urgence toute particulière
ce travail est également l'occasion de
démontrer les capacités d'anticipation
et d'analyse du Sénat dans la suite de
notre rapport présenté à août 2022 nous
étions fixés comme objectif initial de
changer le droit avant la prochaine
saison des feux ce sera peut-être pas
possible dans un tel délai d'autant que
c'est un constat essentiel de notre
rapport la saison des feux commence de
plus en plus tôt dans l'année et
d'ailleurs depuis ce weekend les
Alpes-Maritimes sont déjà en train de
brûler
mais nos échanges constructifs avaient
les administrations centrales des
concentrées avec des établissements
publics chargés de la forêt l'engagement
tout récent de la procédure accélérée et
les lents collectifs que nous sentons de
la part des acteurs de terrain me font
former le vœu que la proposition de l'AS
soit adopté au plus vite pour revenir à
cette première lecture au Sénat je me
félicité que nos deux commissions
d'origine l'aménagement du territoire et
les affaires économiques et puis
bénéficier d'un cadre institutionnel
favorable à la collaboration et au
croisement d'approche complémentaires
grâce à la constitution d'une commission
spéciale pour l'examen de ce texte si
son jointes dans un esprit d'entente
cordiale les compétences de la
commission des lois et des Finances en
matière de sécurité civile et de
fiscalité ce format Haddock a donc
contribué à la remarquable d'assiduité
et aux interventions toujours à bon
escient et constructive de nombreux
membres de la commission spéciale
les commissaires ont pu constater lors
du cycle d'audition ou des principaux
acteurs concernés que ces derniers
fédérations des liloko administration
des trois ministères concernés forces de
sécurité civile propriétaire et
gestionnaires forestiers agriculteurs et
monde associatifs ont accueilli très
positivement ce texte la proposition de
loi du reste était largement issue des
contributions de ces mêmes acteurs lors
du premier cycle d'audition que nous
avions menée au printemps 2022 notre
objectif étant d'aboutir au texte le
plus robuste et le plus consensuel
possible en vue de son inscription
rapide à l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée
nationale les rapporteurs ont eu pour
ligne directrice d'intégrer au texte
autant que faire ce peu les suggestions
venant de part et d'autre dans notre
émission ainsi la Commission spéciale
sur 183 abandonnant déposés 73 ont été
adoptés dans près d'un tiers été
extérieur les travaux de notre
commission spéciale ont permis
d'améliorer l'économie du texte par
rapport à sa version initiale et de
l'enrichir par dutyles comp que l'on
peut regrouper en quatre axes destiné
notamment premièrement tirer les leçons
des retours d'expérience des feux
notamment après les épisodes
dévastateurs qui ont embrasé la Provence
en 2021 et la Gironde en juillet dernier
deuxièmement consacrée le relais
essentiel des sylviculteurs et des
agriculteurs dans la prévention
troisièmement intégrer la stratégie
nationale et interministériel incendie
dans notre politique de gestion de l'eau
et de protection de la biodiversité et
quatrièmement renforcer le caractère
dissuasif des sanctions en cas d'absence
de mise en oeuvre ou de non-respects des
mesures de prévention et de lutte contre
l'intensification du risque incendie je
laisserai le rapporteur présenté la
direction dans laquelle ils ont souhaité
aller avec sur leur volet respectifs
mais je voudrais à titre personnel à
tirer votre attention sur un premier
sujet
notre stratégie stratégie de protection
de la forêt et des espaces végétalisés
repose sur deux piliers
indissociablement liés le premier relève
de la préparation de la forêt à éviter
le feu et le cas échéant à s'en défendre
plus facilement le deuxième est celui de
l'organisation d'adaptation et le
renforcement des moyens de lutte ces
deux vecteurs d'intervention ont
évidemment une place singulière un ordre
chronologique dans notre un doctrine
d'attaques des fenaissants ces deux
vecteurs ont une même importance
néanmoins il se distingue par leur
dimension économique respectives il
apparaît qu'un neuro investit au titre
de la prévention et de la protection de
la forêt préserve l'équivalent de 20
euros engagés lorsqu'elle est en feu le
concept de valeur du Sauvet souligne
alors l'importance cruciale de la notion
de décentabilité
dans un second temps insister sur trois
progrès majeurs que me semble permettre
la proposition de loi pour les
territoires premièrement une meilleure
articulation de la politique de
prévention des feux de forêt avec
l'ensemble des autres politiques
publiques ainsi nous avons réaffirmé la
nécessité de tenir compte de la
protection des forêts contre l'incendie
dans les documents de gestion durable
des forêts dans la stratégie nationale
des héros protégés dans les schémas
d'aménagement et de gestion des eaux
dans les documents d'urbanisme les
travaux de notre commission ont mis en
évidence le besoin d'une gestion
interministérielle de cette
problématique la nécessité de pouvoir
procéder à des arbitrages relevant de
l'intérêt général lorsque l'on oppose
parce que l'on ne saurait les conjugués
l'intérêt de la forêt à celui de la
biodiversité il n'est pas acceptable que
les acteurs de terrain soient pris dans
des injonctions contradictoires par
exemple entre le code forestier et le
code de l'environnement et l'objectif du
législateur doit être donné un cadre et
des orientations claires
deuxièmement la poursuite des efforts
pour assurer une application plus
effective et plus complète des
obligations légales de débroussaillement
cela passe à la fois par des
clarifications de cette législation
touffue et par des leviers à la fois
incitatifs et dissuasif
troisièmement l'obligation de réaliser
des plans de protection contre les
incendies dans tous les territoires
classés à risques et plus seulement dans
les zones particulièrement exposées au
risque incendie nous devons œuvrer à la
définition d'adaptation et la
déclinaison d'une politique publique
forte de sa cohérence globale aux
particularismes des territoires et de ce
qui les caractérise rien ne nous tient
plus à cœur en tant que sénateur que de
voter des textes adaptés aux réalités du
terrain dont vous vous êtes sans cesse
fait l'écho
ainsi modifié la proposition de loi a
été adoptée par la commission spéciale à
l'unanimité cette proposition de loi
visant à renforcer la prévention et
l'adulte contre l'intensification et
l'extension du risque incendie poursuit
désormais son cheminement démocratique
en vue de la séance ce sont 135
amendements qui ont été déposés c'est le
signe du grand intérêt porté par le
Sénat chambre des territoires à cette
question cruciale des avant la saison
des feux éprouvante de 2022 je vous
remercie pour votre écoute et vous
laisse sans plus tarder et laisse sans
plus tarder la parole à nos trois
rapporteurs qui vont vous présenter
l'esprit de cette proposition de loi et
les thématiques dont ils ont eu la
charge
merci chers collègues
et maintenant nos trois rapporteurs vont
avoir la tâche un peu lourde de se
partager 10 minutes Monsieur Pascal
Martin première rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues comme l'a dit
Jean-Baptiste il y a quelques minutes
c'est avec une certaine émotion et
satisfaction que nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui pour examiner le fruit de
plus d'un an de travail nous avons
parcouru un long chemin ensemble nous
espérons que le gouvernement et
l'Assemblée nationale permettront au
texte de poursuivre au plus vite sa
route car il y a urgence
j'aborderai pour ma part les articles
dont j'avais la responsabilité au sein
de la commission spéciale je commencerai
par le titre premier qui porte sur la
stratégie nationale et territoriale
permettant de renforcer la prévention et
la lutte contre l'intensification et
l'extension du risque incendie ce titre
a fait l'objet d'un accueil
particulièrement favorable des personnes
entendues la commission lors de l'examen
de son texte a apporté d'utile
amélioration à ce volet par exemple en
prévoyant à l'article premier d'associer
l'Office National des Forêts et le
Centre National de la Propriété
Forestière à la concertation devant
permettre de définir la stratégie
nationale et interministérielle
l'article 3 de la proposition de loi
initiale ne faisait qu'encourager
l'établissement d'un tel document dans
ces territoires nous a donc semblé
nécessaire d'imposer dans les
départements dont les bois et forêts
sont simplement classés à risque
d'incendie un plan de protection des
forêts contre les incendies déjà prévu
dans les zones classées particulièrement
à risque soit élaboré donc nous avons
également complété le titre premier par
deux articles additionnels 7 bis et
cette terre pour intégrer la stratégie
nationale et un terme ministérielle
incendie dans notre politique de gestion
de l'eau et de la protection de la
biodiversité
au sein du titre 2 visant à mieux
réguler les interfaces forêts aux
urbaines j’évoquerai les articles 12 13
et 14 de la proposition de loi relatif à
l'intégration du risque incendie dans
les politiques d'urbanisme là encore
l'accueil a été très positif les mesures
proposées par le texte initial n'ont
donc été modifié calamarge par notre
commission cette partie pourra
d'ailleurs peut-être faire l'objet de
complément dans la suite de la navette
parlementaire au titre 6 visant à
sensibiliser les populations aux risques
incendies deux principaux compléments
méritent l'attention là qui concerne la
responsabilisation des fumeurs en milieu
forestiers abordés par l'inclusion des
gènes mégots parmi les actions que le
code forestier assimile aux causes
pouvant provoquer des incendies
involontaires et la valorisation du rôle
de vigie des gardes champêtre pour la
surveillance de ces mêmes infractions
forestières
je terminerai enfin par le titre 7
particulièrement bien reçu lui aussi par
l'ensemble des acteurs entendus qui
prévoit d'équiper la lutte incendie à la
hauteur du risque c'est le souci dans
l'assurer la conformité à la loi
organique relative aux lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale ou
encore aux exigences du droit de l'Union
européenne qui a été notre fil
conducteur en commission et qui justifie
les modifications du texte initial à
l'article 33 qui exonère les véhicules
des 10 de malus écologique nous avons
souhaité étendre cet exonération à
l'ensemble des véhicules opérationnels
des acteurs de la DFCI enfin avec nos
collègues Girondins particulièrement
concernés par le travail engagé que je
salue et remercie pour leur esprit de
collaboration
nous avons voulu tenir compte du retour
d'expérience des feux qui ont l'an
dernier frappé durement la Gironde en
donnant une assise juridique à la
pratique des coupes tactiques ces coups
ont été mises en oeuvre l'été dernier
pour la première fois depuis les
terribles incendies de 1949 marquant un
changement majeur de doctrine
opérationnelle il convenait de mettre
notre droit en conformité avec ce nouvel
outil qui a démontré toute son
efficacité je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci chers collègues à présent nous
écoutons madame Anne-Catherine Loisier
rapporteur de la commission spéciale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
Michel collègues face à l'aggravation
rapide des risques incendies à la
vulnérabilité grandissante de nos forêts
une part de la réponse réside dans une
gestion active et concertée de la DFCI
par massif en ce sens notre PPL propose
de mobiliser les acteurs du monde
forestier au sens large et d'optimiser
la gestion silicole comme levier de
prévention et de défense des forêts
contre les incendies une forêt non gérée
aujourd'hui est une forêt soumise à plus
de risques risques que le feu se
développe avant d'être détecté risque de
ne pouvoir accéder au feu faute de
desserte aménagé et entretenu risque de
progression rapide de l'incendie
alimentée par une masse combustible pour
répondre à ces risques croissants nous
proposons une stratégie à deux niveaux
tout d'abord renforcer la prévention et
intégrer la prise en compte du risque
incendie dans les documents cadres de la
politique forestière nationale puis
décliner et adapter localement cette
stratégie aux réalités aux pratiques de
gestion durable et les fonctionnelle de
nos massifs cela représente des
contraintes supplémentaires pour les
propriétaires mais les forestiers sont
les premiers conscients de la nécessité
pour préserver leur forêt leur
biodiversité ainsi que la production de
matériaux nous encourageons la gestion
forestière et les documents de gestion
durable qui atténue le risque grâce à
des pratiques sylvicales favorisant la
résilience des massifs l'amélioration
des desserts une meilleure connaissance
et une surveillance le renforcement de
la présence humaine et de l'expertise en
forêt nous préconisons des démarches
collectives la mobilisation des acteurs
locaux et singulièrement des élus la
mise en place d'associations syndicales
de gestion ou de DFCI par leur
connaissance leur veille attentive et
leur gestion régulière des espaces
naturels ces acteurs sont déterminants
dans l'efficacité de la stratégie de
prévention et de lutte nous appréhendons
la DFCI à l'échelle du massif forestier
plus pertinent pour que les acteurs
s'approprient la politique de prévention
et pour prendre en compte les réalités
territoriales de nos forêt souvent
au-delà et parfois en deçà des réalités
administratives nous ouvrons un droit de
préemption DFCI aux communes sur les
forêts non gérées comportant des enjeux
au regard de la DFCI attendu par les
maires ce droit de préemption DFCI
justifiée par un risque avéré pour la
sécurité publique s'activera dans des
conditions encadrées nos propositions
mettent l'accent sur la forêt privée
majoritaire sur le territoire national
morcelé et peut gérer à ce jour à son
bénéfice nous proposons d'étendre les
plans simples de gestion et le
dispositif fiscal défi forêt près de 800
000 nouveaux hectares seraient ainsi
impactés par ces mesures
d'accompagnement pour mener à bien cet
enjeu majeur de gestion de la forêt
privée nous nous appuyons sur le Centre
National de la Propriété Forestière
organismes présents sur tous nos
territoires qui agrent les PSG qui
prodigue conseil et animations les
missions supplémentaires que nous lui
confions appellent une compensation à
coup complet par l'État que nous n'avons
pu faire figurer dans cette proposition
et pour laquelle nous aurons besoin de
votre soutien lors du prochain PLF
l'ensemble des dispositions proposées
tire les leçons des attaques sanitaires
et des feux hors normes de 2022 elles
inscrivent dans le Code forestier des
principes généraux de diversification
des essences déco conditionnelles
appliquer aujourd'hui par la plupart des
gestionnaires forestiers dans les
reboisement et ils seront déclinés de
manière opportune dans les documents
cadres régionaux voilà mes chers
collègues les outils mobilisés que nous
proposons de mobiliser au profit des
acteurs locaux pour une plus grande
efficacité face à la prévention et la
lutte contre les incendies je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
Olivier riezmann également rapporteur de
la commission spéciale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues comme mes collègues
Jean-Baptiste Anne-Catherine Loisier et
Pascal Martin c'est avec une grande
satisfaction que je prends la parole
devant vous pour vous présenter ce texte
qui me tient particulièrement à coeur
j'aborderai les articles que j'ai
rapporté au sein de la commission
spéciale en commençant par les
obligations légales de débroussaillement
aborder au titre de cet axe est tout à
fait essentiel à la prévention des
incendies et pourtant les Old ne sont
réalisés qu'à hauteur de 30%. les Old
évitent de mobiliser des moyens de lutte
pour protéger les habitations et
permettent donc aux pompiers de se
concentrer sur la guerre du feu les Old
sont surtout la meilleure garantie
existante pour les particuliers les
photos aériennes prises après l'incendie
de Gonfaron dans le Var en 2021 montrait
clairement que les personnes qui avaient
effectué leur débroussaillement selon
les normes n'avaient eu aucun dégât sur
leur propriété
sur ce volet relatif aux old nous nous
réjouissons là aussi des commentaires
positifs des personnes entendues sur nos
propositions
le travail de commission nous a permis
d'adopter plusieurs amendements
techniques de clarification
rédactionnelle
par ailleurs à l'article 11 nous avons
souhaité rendre le dispositif plus
robuste en punissant pénalement les
attestations fournies aux assurances
faisant état de débroussaillement qui
n'ont en fait pas été réalisés
à l'article 10 nous avons par
pragmatisme et souci d'efficacité vous
lui doubler le plafond des dépenses
éligibles au crédit d'impôt au LD enfin
sur proposition de nos collègues
Laurence haribet et Gisèle Jourdan
nous avons introduit un nouvel article 9
bis augmentant les amendes en cas de
non-respect des old
fruit d'un travail engagé avec les
ministères depuis de nombreuses semaines
nous vous proposerons ce soir de
nouvelles propositions techniques
tendant à améliorer la mise en oeuvre de
ces ewld clarification des
responsabilités en cas de superposition
des old modalités de mise en oeuvre des
obligations dans les campings meilleures
informations des acquéreurs ou
locataires par l'intégration des old aux
informations des acquéreurs et des
locataires
facilitation de la mise en oeuvre de
l'amende administrative par le préfet
obligation de nettoyage systématique des
coupes de bois dans les périmètres old
voici de façon succincte les
propositions complémentaires que nous
vous présenterons tout à l'heure
le titre 5 me permet de mettre en avant
le rôle majeur des exploitants agricoles
dans la prévention des feux de forêt qui
les proposé de consacrer les
agriculteurs ont fait preuve d'un
dévouement remarqué en se mobilisant à
l'été 2022 et en mettant à disposition
leurs outils et leur force de travail
dans la lutte contre les feux de forêt
en particulier en Gironde
nous souhaitons par ce volet mettre à
l'honneur le rôle moins visible mais
tout aussi crucial dans la prévention
sur les articles 28 et 29 permettant au
préfet de prescrire des travaux
agricoles la nuit ou des coupures de
combustibles nous avons eu très peu
voire pas d'amendements en commission
cela traduit une prise de conscience du
rôle essentiel des agriculteurs dans la
prévention des feux
à l'article 25 nous avons cherché à
convaincre de la pertinence de notre
dérogation à l'indemnité de défrichement
dans les cas où ce dernier a pour but
une valorisation agricole ou pastorale
renforçant la défense des forêts contre
les incendies cet article avait en effet
suscité les craintes et les plaintes
crainte des forestiers et que des
défrichements abusifs prennent prétexte
de la DFCI et plein du monde agricole
pour lesquels l'indemnité de
défrichement même réduite de moitié
restaient trop élevés pour être
intéressante nous avons encadré le
dispositif par un décret est limité son
champ au seul cas ou un contrat engage
d'exploitant à des coupures agricoles
pérennes ce qui permet de concilier à la
fois les intérêts du monde agricole et
du monde forestier et je crois que nous
sommes parvenus à rassurer
c'est la preuve que forestier et
agriculteurs peuvent travailler main
dans la main pour prévenir ce risque qui
est de plus en plus intégré merci
merci chers collègues et à présent la
parole de Madame Dominique form ministre
délégué chargé des collectivités locales
territoriales pardon et de la ruralité
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Bassim Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs Martins loisiers éricman
mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs
les forêts nous rendent des services
précieux qu'il s'agissent de service
économique en fournissant du bois
matériaux et du bois énergie des
services environnementaux en termes de
biodiversité ou de stockage de carbone
en tant que ministre chargé des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité je rappelle que les forêts sont
un véritable atout pour l'activité de
nos territoires ruraux
elles doivent donc être gérées et
exploitées de manière durable pour
continuer à fournir tous ces services
économiques comme environnementaux à
tous les Français mais elles doivent
également être défendues face aux
événements extérieurs les incendies hors
normes de l'été 2022 généré par un
concours de sécheresse et de température
particulièrement élevée ont constitué
une preuve éclatante et douloureuse des
effets du changement climatique en
matière de feu de forêt
et ce ne sont pas les premiers incendies
que nous constaterons en effet pour 2023
les incendies survenus dans les
Alpes-Maritimes et encore récemment nous
laissent craindre des étés très
difficiles
les incendies ont toujours existé dans
le sud de la France et reviennent
malheureusement chaque été
une politique volontariste de défense
des forêts contre l'incendie était mise
en place dans les années 1980 cette
politique a produit de très bons
résultats réussissant à diviser par deux
voire par 3 les surfaces incendiées
entre les années 80 et aujourd'hui je
souhaite sincèrement rendre hommage à
l'engagement des structures et personnes
mobilisées dans la prévention et la
lutte contre les incendies de forêts je
veux notamment remercier chaleureusement
au nom du gouvernement tous les acteurs
sapeurs-pompiers personnels de la
sécurité civile sapeurshofter forestier
sa peur bref toutes les personnes qui
s'engagent pour la sauvegarde de nos
forêts pour l'excellent travail qu'ils
effectuent au quotidien
néanmoins le climat change les incendies
de l'été 2022 les centres voire une
intensification du risque dans les
régions historiquesment concernées du
sud-est du Sud-Ouest et de la Corse mais
aussi et surtout une extension du risque
dans des régions jusqu'ici préservées je
pense notamment aux régions de l'ouest
du Grand Est du centre de la France
territoire dans lesquels nous n'avions
pas vu d'incendie de cette ampleur
auparavant
notre politique de défense des forêts
contre l'incendie et de lutte contre ces
incendies doit donc être renforcée et
actualiser au regard d'un risque
amplifié et étendu sur davantage de nos
territoires
je souhaite saluer le travail du Sénat
et des trois sénateurs Martin Loisier
Rickman qui se sont saisis rapidement de
cet enjeu et qui ont lancé début 2022
une mission d'information sur
l'intensification et l'extension du
risque incendie le rapport d'information
publié en août dernier de grandes
qualités et trouve aujourd'hui un écho
dans cette proposition de loi j'y vois
aussi l'engagement de longue date du
Sénat les garde des enjeux forestiers en
gelier la vie des collectivités
territoriales naturellement mais aussi
et plus globalement aux questions
d'aménagement et d'avenir de nos
territoires
votre proposition de loi montre la
diversité des politiques à conduire pour
assurer la défense des forêts contre
l'incendie
ma présence devant vous aujourd'hui pour
représenter le gouvernement traduit le
caractère multidimensionnel de ce sujet
qui mobilise les compétences de trois
ministères le ministère de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer le ministère de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires et le ministère de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire le Gouvernement partage les
objectifs de votre proposition de loi
conformément aux annonces du président
de la République le 28 octobre dernier
plusieurs mesures ont été annoncées
visant à renforcer notre politique
nationale de défense déforer contre
l'incendie
tout d'abord la prévention est reste
essentielle notre stratégie est d'éviter
le départ de feu et d'être en mesure
d'attaquer les feux naissants pour
éviter leur propagation des moyens
supplémentaires ont ainsi été accordés
dès 2023 à l'Office national des forêts
pour lui permettre de renforcer ses
missions de surveillance et de première
intervention et de les étendre dans les
territoires nouvellement concernés par
ce risque des moyens supplémentaires ont
également été apportés par mon collègue
Marc féno à l'Association régionale de
défense des forêts contre les incendies
des Landes de Gascogne massif riche
d'une organisation impliquant les
propriétaires forestiers se renfort de
moyens se poursuivra en 2024
mais il faut aussi agir sur l'origine
des feux lorsqu'on sait que 90% des
départs de feu sont liés à une activité
humaine notre priorité d'agir sur les
interfaces entre forêts et habitations
soyons clairs les obligations légales de
débroussaillement fixés dans le Code
forestier doivent être mieux mis en
œuvre en effet lorsque la mise en œuvre
est effective les résultats parlent de
même
avec Christophe Béchu et Gérald Darmanin
nous avons ainsi engagé des actions au
niveau national et local pour
sensibiliser le public concerné
accompagner les élus locomotives
sanctionner les négligences volontaires
des propositions de simplification et de
remobilisation des acteurs sont ainsi en
cours de rédaction en vue d'une
publication à l'été 2023 par voie
réglementaire et à cadre législatif
constant
cependant la proposition de loi examiner
ce jour va permettre d'aller encore plus
loin en apportant des éléments de
clarification de simplification et de
responsabilisation
nos moyens de lutte doivent en effet
être renforcés pour limiter la
propagation des feux protéger nos
concitoyens sécuriser nos
infrastructures nous allons beaucoup
évoquer la prévention qui est
essentielle mais pas suffisante malgré
tout ce que l'on peut faire le feu
arrivera et c'est pour cela que la lutte
doit être également organisée et que le
Président de la République a décidé de
renforcer les moyens terrestres et
aériens dès cette année enfin nous
sommes loin de tout savoir sur
l'évolution de ce risque nous avons
aussi missionné les inspections
générales pour actualiser la
cartographie du risque incendie et nous
permet de définir nos organisations
cibles pour y faire face dans les années
à venir les conclusions de cette mission
seront connues d'ici cet été nous
permettront de nous préparer pour
l'année prochaine et les années
suivantes
mais cette proposition de loi est donc
un signal fort envoyé aux propriétaires
forestiers au riverains des forêts aux
associations de protection de
l'environnement aux élus locaux et à
tous ceux qui agissent avec engagement
au quotidien dans la prévention et la
lutte contre les incendies de forêts il
s'agit de leur montrer que nous sommes
capables ensemble d'avancer pour nous
adapter au changement climatique
la proposition de loi qui est à l'ordre
du jour aujourd'hui présente des aspects
extrêmement intéressants plusieurs
mesures traitent de la défense des
forêts contre les incendies vous
proposez en premier lieu l'inscription
dans la loi d'une stratégie nationale et
interministérielle de défense des forêts
contre l'incendie qui permettra de
mobiliser pleinement l'ensemble des
acteurs publics et privés concernés vous
proposez de faire évoluer la liste des
territoires réputés particulièrement
exposés au risque d'incendie qui
constituent un moyen d'être réactif face
aux évolutions du changement climatique
de même votre texte suggère d'améliorer
l'articulation des mesures des DFCI avec
d'autres politiques publiques comme
l'urbanisme la protection des sites
classés nous serons collectivement plus
à même de répondre de voir de lisibilité
pour les administrer
par ailleurs vous proposez d'agir sur
l'un des instruments de la DFCI à savoir
les obligations légales de
débroussaillement les Old par des
dispositions quelquefois simples et
efficaces à titre d'exemple je salue la
proposition d'information de l'acheteur
d'un bien sur ces obligations je salue
aussi la reprise dans cette proposition
de loi de ces deux évolutions issues de
réflexion passée tenues dans le cadre
des Assises de la forêt du Bois à savoir
l'abaissement à 20 hectares de
l'obligation de disposer d'un plan
simple de gestion et la systématisation
de la télé déclaration par contre je
souhaite préciser que pour le
gouvernement il s'agit bien de rester à
une proposition qui traite strictement
de la prévention et de la lutte contre
les incendies et non d'avoir une loi
relative à la gestion forestière
l'attente de nos concitoyens porte en
effet sur les incendies c'est pourquoi
nous souhaiterons en rester
principalement aux deux propositions que
nous trouvons équilibrer et issus du
travail des rapporteurs et du passage en
commission en conclusion je souhaite à
nouveau salut la qualité du travail des
auteurs de cette proposition de loi et
de la commission spéciale
et vous dire ma confiance sur le fait
que nous pouvons enrichir ensemble ce
texte afin d'assurer la cohérence et
l'efficacité des mesures proposées dont
nous partageons les objectifs je vous
remercie
très bien Madame la Ministre dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est d'abord madame Monique de
Marco pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire
et 5 minutes chers collègues
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers
voici une liste non exhaustive des
nombreuses communes meurtries par les
flammes cet été au total 30000 hectares
de forêt sont partis en fumée en Gironde
et plus de 60 000 hectares en France
cet été la Gironde a brûlé d'un feu
monstrueux combattu avec abnégation par
les pompiers donc je veux ici saluer le
courage
ces catastrophes qui étaient jusqu'à
présent exceptionnel seront demain la
norme en 2021 et 2022 nous avons connu
les trois plus grands incendies de ces
40 dernières années il y a 10 ans les
prévisions météo placées ces conditions
en 2040 2050 il n'y a aucun doute ses
feux sont les conséquences directes du
changement climatique
des feux plus nombreux plus étendues
plus violents voilà quoi nous devons
nous préparer de l'Aveyron à la Bretagne
en passant par la Gironde et les Vosges
après le sud-est l'ensemble du
territoire français et dorénavant
concerné
les experts sont unanimes près de 50%
des forêts françaises seront menacées
par ce risque incendie d'ici 2050
malgré la mobilisation de 2000
sapeurs-pompiers malgré les 50000
évacuations préventives et malgré la
solidarité des milliers de bénévoles les
feux en Gironde ont souligné notre
vulnérabilité aux risques incendie et
nous devons en tirer les leçons
je tiens à saluer le travail de la
mission de contrôle il se rapporteur à
l'origine cette proposition de loi avec
70 recommandations le rapport
d'information
issu de cette émission a permis
d'établir un diagnostic clair et partagé
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
traduit l'essentiel de ces
recommandations il permet notamment de
renforcer les moyens des 10 de favoriser
l'adaptations des forêts aux changements
climatiques de créer un nouveau droit de
préemption pour les communes ou
d'établir des cartes d'aléa pour suivre
l'évolution du risque
après les feux gigantesques qui ont
marqué des têtes 2022 notre président
Emmanuel Macron avait annoncé qu'une
stratégie nouvelle de lutte et de
prévention contre les incendies ce texte
porte des mesures fortes il offre un
début de réponse et ouvre la voie mais
il manque d'ambition sur plus en point
essentielle la prévention du risque
incendie et la pierre angulaire une
stratégie de long terme alors que 95%
des départs de feu sont d'origine
humaine acquérir une nouvelle culture du
risque est un enjeu majeur
mais les mesures proposées dans ce texte
nous semblent insuffisantes
nous déplorons également l'absence
d'éléments sur le renforcement des
moyens humains au sein de l'Office
National des Forêts ces agents sont des
centimètres du clean humain et de la
forêt pourtant en 30 ans leur effectifs
sont passés de 15000 agents
de même en pleine crise du volontariat
et face à l'intensification du risque il
s'agira d'augmenter le nombre de
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels et les
moyens qui leur sont alloués
notre politique de luxe contre les
incendies doit te dire compte de
l'évolution du risque pour l'ensemble du
territoire cette stratégie passe par
l'affectation équitable des moyens
nationaux
alors qu'un incendie doit être repéré et
traité dès qu'il apparaît la protection
aérienne des Canadairs et des dash
s'avère cruciales le temps
d'autorisation et l'éloignement des
appareils ne sont pas compatibles avec
la temporalité des incendies il faut une
faute flotte plus conséquente une
répartition territoriale adaptée
au regard de l'exposition colossale du
sud-ouest de la France au risque
incendie un prépositionnement des moyens
aériens par exemple en
nouvelle-aquitaine paraît essentiel nous
demandons ce sens une étude
d'opportunité pour créer une seconde
base aérienne de la sécurité civile
comme si était engagé Gérard Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur en octobre
dernier
enfin nous restons vigilants sur les
éventuelles dérives que ce texte
pourrait engendrer la prévention et la
lutte contre les incendies nécessitent
des aménagements indispensables et des
efforts importants mais elle ne peut se
faire au détriment de la biodiversité et
des écosystèmes qui sont essentiels pour
adapter nos forêts et réduire le risque
permettez-moi mes chers collègues de
citer Charles Darwin pour appeler ici
que les espèces qui survivent ne sont
pas les espèces les plus fortes ni les
plus intelligentes mais celles qui
s'adaptent le mieux aux changements
l'équilibre a trouvé n'est pas simple
pour participer à se rééquilibrage sans
jamais perdre de vue l'objectif de ce
texte nous proposerons plusieurs
amendements au cours des débats nous
espérons qu'il sera adopté afin
d'apporter des réponses à nature des
enjeux cette proposition de loi
constitue néanmoins une première étape
essentielle pour prévenir et lutter
contre le risque incendie le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire votera
pour cette proposition de loi je vous
remercie super collègue
la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Bernard buis pour le groupe RDP et pour
6 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la commission
spéciale Madame et Monsieur les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues nous
avons tous à l'esprit des images de cet
été ou 72000 hectares de nos forêts sont
partis en fumée et avec eux autant
d'hectares de notre patrimoine naturel
j'ai une pensée particulière pour mon
département de la Drôme ou 30 feux de
forêt dans celui de Romillé dans mon
diwanatal qui a brûlé 380 hectares et
mobilisé plus de 800 sapeurs-pompiers
pendant 10 jours je tiens à les
remercier ainsi que les agriculteurs qui
ont activement contribué à alimenter en
eau nos sapeurs-pompiers je remercie
également les habitants qui ont amélioré
le repas de nos valeurs
cet été heureusement nous avons pu
compter sur le courage l'efficacité et
l'exceptionnel sens de l'engagement de
nos forces de sécurité civiles et des
élus locaux je tiens ici à les saluer
nous avons également pu compter sur
l'aide de nos partenaires européens avec
l'activation du mécanisme de protection
civile de l'Union européenne permettant
de mobiliser quatre avions de la flotte
reste io
le caractère hors norme de l'été 2022 ne
doit pas cacher le fait que
l'intensification des feux de forêt est
un mouvement de fond sur le pourtour
méditerranéen français les surfaces
brûlées pourraient augmenter de 80%
d'ici à 2050 les conséquences du
changement climatique se manifestent de
manière spectaculaire pour celles et
ceux ne venant pas de régions
traditionnellement sujette au feu de
forêt l'été dernier a marqué un
changement de paradigme avec près d'un
département sur deux concernés à
l'horizon 2050 50% des Landes et des
forêts métropolitaines seront exposées à
un risque incendie élevé contre un tiers
il y a un peu plus d'une décennie cette
extension est également temporelle
puisque la période à risque devrait être
trois fois plus longue et que les feux
hivernaux vont se multiplier
dès le mois de mai 2022 le Sénat s'est
saisi de ce sujet puisque la commission
des affaires économiques et de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable on constitué une
mission de contrôle relative à la
prévention et à la lutte contre
l'intensification et l'extension du
risque incendie mission à l'origine du
texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui je
veux ici remercier les rapporteurs qui
l'ont élaboré les travaux de cette
commission et de cette mission ont mis
en lumière le constat de la future
vulnérabilité de notre stratégie de
lutte contre les feux de forêt qui bien
qu'étant aujourd'hui un modèle en Europe
doit évoluer sans changement notre
stratégie de lutte ne suffira pas face à
l'intensification et l'extension des
feux de forêt la proposition de loi
particulièrement dense qui a résulté des
travaux de notre mission répond pour
partir à cette nouvelle problématique en
mettant l'accent sur l'aménagement du
territoire la gestion durable la
valorisation de la forêt et la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des acteurs
au premier rang desquels les
agriculteurs maillant vous êtes dans
l'élaboration du modèle de lutte contre
les forêts quand les feux de forêt au
21e siècle si depuis 2017 nous avons
investi de manière conséquente dans la
sécurité civile avec une augmentation
budgétaire de 40% et l'acquisition de
nouveaux avions Dash force et de
constater que la mobilisation des moyens
financiers est une condition nécessaire
mais insuffisante pour répondre à
l'intensification de la pression qui
s'exerce sur nos massifs forestiers
au-delà des budgets nous avons clarifié
le cadre d'intervention des 10 conforter
les plans communaux de sauvegarde et
valoriser l'engagement et le volontariat
lors de l'examen de la loi Matra je
tiens particulièrement la reconnaissance
de la Nation du satiscrifice ultime des
sapeurs-pompiers par la création de la
mention mort pour le service de la
République et la reconnaissance des
enfants de sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels et volontaires décédé un
service comme étant pupille de la
République
nous sommes tous conscients que si la
France a un modèle de lutte contre les
incendies performants et reconnus à
travers le monde nous devons néanmoins
adapter nos politiques et nos
territoires aux conséquences du
dérèglement climatique autrement dit
nous devons améliorer la prévention
renforcer les moyens de lutte et
accélérer le roboisement poste incendie
ce texte a-t-elle à ses trois tâches et
comporte un voglet d'optimisation de
gestion de nos forêts que nos auditions
ont mis en lumière comme étant un
élément central du modèle à construire
pour les années à venir le
décloisonnement administratif
qu'implique la stratégie nationale et
interministérielle de défense des forêts
et des surfaces boisées contre les
incendies poursuit la logique
d'optimisation d'utilisation des
ressources et d'assouplissement des
procédures visant à renforcer la
performance opérationnelle en témoignent
des exemples d'apport de la commission
puisque nous intégrons l'ONF et le
Centre National de la Propriété
Forestière dans la concertation de la
stratégie nationale et
interministérielle nous rendons
obligatoires dans les l'histoire les
plus à risque l'élaboration d'un plan de
protection des forêts contre les
incendies nous instaurons un droit de
préemption des parcelles de forêt sans
document de gestion durable et
présentant un enjeu au regard de la
défense des forêts contre l'incendie au
profit des communes s'engageant à
intégrer la parcelle au régime forestier
nous renforçons l'application des
obligations légales de débroussaillement
nous conditionnons les aides d'État à
des choix d'essence et de gestion
adaptés aux risques incendie nous
reconnaissons enfin le rôle primordial
des agriculteurs et de la sylviculture
dans la prévention des feux de forêt
le texte en l'état permet donc de faire
de la prévention de lutter à la racine
contre l'intensification et l'extension
du risque d'incendie dans nos forêts
mais également d'adapter nos forêts et
de conforter l'aménagement du territoire
comme pierre angulaire de la protection
de notre patrimoine naturel pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons le groupe RDPI
votera ce texte je vous remercie et bien
maintenant la parole est à Madame
Laurence arrivée pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
madame et Messieurs les rapporteurs de
la commission spéciale
chers collègues 72000 hectares brûlés en
France en 2022 plus de 30 000 en Gironde
contre une moyenne de 8500 les 10
dernières années si le risque incendie
avait globalement été contenu jusque là
par une politique volontariste de
défense des forêts les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique change
totalement la donne on le sait les zones
à risque vont s'étendre d'ici 2050 le
GIEC estime dans son scénario le plus
pessimiste que le danger d'incendie
moyen pourrait augmenter de 2 à 4% par
décennie
cette PPL sert initié dans le cadre
d'une mission flash avant le terrible
été 22 sans Girondins à bord si je puis
dire mais qui s'est rendu sur les lieux
à la fin de l'été et qui a largement
ouvert ses travaux au sénateur Girondins
arrivent donc dans un contexte qu'on
pourrait qualifier d'urgence nous
saluons le travail
transpartisan et collaboratif
mené par les quatre mousquetaires le
président et les rapporteurs et
leurs capacité à intégrer au texte
nombre de remarques faites durant les
auditions notre groupe a été actif et
constructif avec une quinzaine
d'amendements adoptés dès l'examen en
commission notamment la prise en compte
des spécificités organisationnelles des
massifs forestiers et le rôle d'acteurs
comme la DFCI là où elle est présente la
prise en compte du risque incendie dans
les documents
urbanisme même si cela nous semble pas
encore suffisants la mise en place d'un
congé spécial supplémentaire pour les
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires la mise en
place d'une communication spécifique aux
propriétaires de terrain concernés par
les Old et l'augmentation des amendes
soulignons aussi que nombre de nos
amendements ont été satisfaits par ceux
des rapporteurs adoptés en commission
notamment concernant la reconnaissance
législative des coupes tactiques le
caractère obligatoire de l'élobe
l'élaboration des ppfci dans les
territoires à risque d'incendie
l'exonération de la TI CPE pour les
véhicules du 10 ou encore la réduction
des cotisations patronales pour les
employeurs de sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires une disposition que nous
avions déjà proposé lors de l'examen de
la loi visant à consolider notre modèle
de sécurité civile dont le rapporteur
était Patrick canaire de en fait cet
après-midi nous examinons un texte assez
complet avec des avancées notoires
cependant nous présenterons quelques
amendements de compléments concernant le
renforcement de l'Association des élus
et des acteurs locaux notamment les as
des FCI pour favoriser une logique
ascendante et non pas descendante la
question de l'eau et du lien défense
extérieure plangestion de l'eau et
l'amélioration de la connaissance des
voies d'accès des pistes DFCI avec un
système de mise à jour de la
cartographie en conclusion au-delà du
texte nous voterons que nous voterons
nous voulons souligner que les bonnes
volontés ne suffiront pas et c'est sans
doute la limite de cette proposition de
loi qui ne vous appartient pas mais qui
appartient au gouvernement donner de
nouvelles missions aux acteurs et
intégrer le risque incendie dans tous
les documents
pareil une évidence aujourd'hui mais
encore faut-il avoir les moyens de les
mettre en oeuvre efficacement l'État
devra prendre ses responsabilités
rappelons que les moyens humains et
financiers tendent à la baisse aussi
bien dans le domaine forestier que dans
celui plus global de la prévention des
risques c'est au Sénat qu'on doit le
sauvetage des moyens de l'ONF lors de la
dernière discussion budgétaire la
deuxième limite de ce texte qui est
c'est le fait d'être consacré mais c'est
l'objet même du texte à la seule
prévention alors que la question de la
lutte pose aussi des questions de moyens
le président de la République a présenté
une nouvelle stratégie en octobre 2022
vous en avez parlé madame la ministre
mais nous attendons toujours une grande
loi de programmation de la forêt et une
territorialisation des moyens aériens
pour lutter contre les feux hors normes
qui pourraient malheureusement
devenir la norme merci merci
la parole est maintenant madame
Marie-Claude varayas pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le Président
de la Commission madame et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues les
incendies que nous avons connues l'été
dernier ont détruit ça a été dit plus de
66000 hectares de ce bien commun que
sont nos forêts françaises Gironde
Bouches-du-Rhône mais aussi Bretagne les
incendies ont surpris par leur intensité
mais aussi par leur étendue géographique
des forêts habituellement épargnées par
les feux estivaux sont partis en fumée
dans mon seul département d'ailleurs en
Dordogne ce sont 280 hectares qui ont
été détruits ce qui semblait hier
exceptionnel et donc en passe de devenir
la norme c'est ce que nous appelons
c'est ce que c'est ce que nous appelle
la mission d'information sénatoriale
constituer l'été dernier en effet les
conclusions de cette mission pointent
une intensification des feux en région
méditerranéenne les surfaces brûlées
pourraient augmenter de 80% d'ici 2050
elle souligne l'extension géographique
du risque à des départements peu touchés
et le développement
on dit de végétation ou de terre
agricoles pire il y a plus de il y a
plus de saison de feu la période de
risque fort sera trois fois plus longue
les incendies colossaux de l'été dernier
nous rappellent que le changement
climatique est déjà là comme un atteste
d'ailleurs une fois encore le rapport du
GIEC ils ont mis en lumière la nécessité
de penser de nouvelles stratégies
d'adaptation pour la forêt la nécessité
de renforcer les moyens de prévention et
de lutte contre les incendies il nous
rappelle aussi que nos forêts sont
fragiles outre le feu la succession de
sécheresse affaiblit les arbres les
rendant plus vulnérables aux attaques
d'insectes et autres parasites nous
assistons ainsi aux dépérissement de
certaines espèces en ce sens nous ne
pouvons que saluer le travail effectué
par les auteurs de cette proposition de
loi qui nous rappelle la fragilité de ce
patrimoine commun et la nécessité de le
préserver en effet la stratégie
française qui a consisté à renforcer la
prévention et la lutte contre les
incendies qui a permis du des années de
maîtriser la survenance de feu dit à
normaux est aujourd'hui bousculé par les
changements climatiques c'est pourquoi
nous partageons la volonté de nos
collègues rapporteurs d'anticiper le
risque émergent en l'intégrant de
manière plus étendue dans les documents
d'urbanisme et de planification des
territoires jusque là épargné par les
incendies de grande ampleur ainsi que la
prise en compte dans ces documents des
espaces urbains des terres agricoles et
des massifs forestiers dans une logique
de protection mutuelle nous choix nous
saluons aussi le renforcement des
obligations de débroussaillement en
effet la question des zones d'interface
habitat forêt est essentiel car dans ces
espaces le risque de départ de feu est
élevé et la difficile protection par les
pompiers et coûteuse et à cet égard il
serait opportun que les communes
bénéficient d’ailleurs de dispositifs
d'accompagnement y compris financiers
nous partageons également le
renforcement de la sensibilisation des
citoyens élus et professionnelle
concernés pour autant si les objectifs
de ce texte sont louables et que les
outils proposés sont pertinents encore
une fois les moyens restent insuffisants
tous les acteurs que nous avons
additionné le rappel à moyen constant il
est impossible que les services de
prévention puissent maintenir leur
efficacité leur efficacité face à des
feux de plus en plus intenses et
fréquents comme le rappeler déjà le
président de la Fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers je le cite le
dérèglement climatique s'accélère il
faut accroître le nombre de bombardiers
d'eau avion comme hélicoptère il faut
aussi augmenter les moyens humains et ce
sans attendre de même aucun
investissement aussi important soit-il
dans la lutte contre les incendies ne
permettra d'empêcher les incendies
extrêmes il nous faut investir dans une
politique forestière préventive qui
permettra la résilience de nos forêts a
commencé par la désertification des
essences les forestiers doivent
renouveler les peuplements dépérissants
et adapter les forêts françaises en
tenant compte des risques futurs il nous
faut également renforcer les moyens
humains et financiers face à
l'intensification du risque incendie
alors que la force de frappe des
services incendie tient au maillage
territorial plus de 2700 centres
d'incendie et de secours ont fermé ces
20 dernières années enfin les
difficultés à contenir les feux dans la
région Sud-Ouest cet été nous ont
rappelé le besoin d'une base aérienne de
sécurité civile à l'Ouest afin
d'accroître la rapidité et l'intensité
des interventions par Canadair par
ailleurs en 35 ans l'ONF qui gère près
de 25% de la forêt métropolitaine a
perdu près de 40% de ses effectifs de
16000 salariés que quand elle office en
1986 il n'en reste plus que 8400
aujourd'hui auquel l'État continue
pourtant de confier un nombre équivalent
de mission et exige une plus grande
rentabilité les 10 l'ONF le Centre
National de la Propriété Forestière sont
des acteurs publics garants de la
résilience et de la résistance de la
forêt ils doivent disposer des moyens
matériels et humains nécessaires à
l'accomplissement de leur mission qu'il
faut bien dire se complexifier malgré
ses réserves nous voterons en faveur de
cette proposition de loi
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent Monsieur Jacques le nez pour le
groupe Union centriste et il dispose de
8 minutes
le président madame la ministre monsieur
le Président de la commission spéciale
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues ce n'est un secret pour
personne le réchauffement climatique va
considérablement aggraver le risque
incendie je viens de veste mais au futur
mais il faut malheureusement déjà en
parler au présent
les feux de forêt et de végétation sont
plus graves d'années en année ceux de
2022 ont été dévastateurs
particulièrement Gironde mais mon
département le Morbihan n'a pas été
épargné non plus un incendie et ravagé
la forêt de légende Brocéliande
l'actualité espagnole nous rappelle
cruellement cette urgence à agir en six
jours le feu il y a détruit la semaine
dernière 4300 hectares et nous ne sommes
évidemment pas à l'abri de ce qui se
passe sur la péninsule ibérique les feux
sont de plus en plus nombreux de plus en
plus rapides et la période de l'année
durant laquelle le risque incendie est
maximal s'allonge les chiffres avancés
par nos rapporteurs Anne-Catherine
Loisier Pascal Martin et Olivier
rianemin dont je salue au passage
implication et la qualité des travaux
ces chiffres sont donc éloquents dans le
sud les surfaces brûlées pour augmenter
de 80% d'ici à 2050 les bois seraient
progressivement remplacés par des makis
d'ici au milieu du siècle la moitié des
langues est forêts métropolitaines
seraient concernées par un risque
incendie élevé
comme un tiers en 2010
contre un tiers en 2010 et la période à
risque fort devrait être trois fois plus
longue d'où le mot du président de la
Fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers de France aujourd'hui
la saison des feux c'est toute l'année
il nous faut réagir car nos dispositifs
de lutte contre l'incendie commence à ne
plus être adapté réagir c'est ce qu'a
fait le Sénat constituant en mai dernier
une mission de contrôle à l'initiative
de notre commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et notre commission des
affaires économiques je salue cette
initiative au nom du groupe de l'Union
centriste
la mission de contrôle a formulé un
grand nombre de propositions nous nous
réjouissons que celle d'entre elles qui
relevait de la loi était si rapidement
concrétisé au sein de la présence
proposition cet exemplaire de plus
l'approche opérée par le texte est
extrêmement concrète car elle est
transverse et l'articule prévention des
feux et lutte contre l'incendie ce qui
constitue à nos yeux le seul moyen
d'apporter une réponse véritablement
efficace au problème posé en allant de
la stratégie nationale des territoriale
au reboisement des parcelles brûlées en
passant par la promotion de la
sylviculture la sensibilisation de
population et l'équipement le champ de
la proposition de loi couvre l'ensemble
des aspects générateurs de risque
d'incendie
le texte qui nous est aujourd'hui soumis
et d'autant plus complet qu'il a été
substantiellement enrichi par la
commission spéciale qui a tenu à tirer
les leçons des feux de 2022 mettre
encore concordance la stratégie incendie
avec les politiques de gestion de l'eau
et de protection de la biodiversité et
renforcer le caractère dissuasif des
sanctions en cas d'absence de mise en
oeuvre ou de non respect des mesures de
prévention et de lutte contre les
risques d'incendie l'un des aspects de
cet enrichissement du texte nous tient
particulièrement à cœur il s'agit de la
consécration du rôle préventif des
forestiers et agriculteurs car nous ne
remporterons cette guerre qu'avec leur
appui
l'implication des communes est aussi
essentielle car le rôle des élus locaux
est fondamental dans la politique
forestière territoriale
en effet l'élu est responsable de la
sécurité sur son territoire il a aussi
un rôle essentiel de médiation dans la
société et la question forestière est
devenue un sujet de préoccupation de nos
concitoyens au-delà des feux dans de
nombreux domaines tels que la protection
de la biodiversité mais aussi la
transition environnementale et
énergétique ainsi l'institution
l'article 22 d'un droit de préemption
pour les communes va dans le bon sens si
une ou plusieurs parcelles sont
identifiées comme étant stratégiques je
dis bien stratégique au regard de la
défense des forêts contre les incendies
favoriser leur appropriation et leur
maîtrise par les communes permet de leur
confier un outil indispensable dans
l'arsenal de mise en protection de leur
territoire et de la population exposée
je pourrais citer encore bien d'autres
mesures essentielles comprises dans ce
texte mais vous l'aurez compris mes
chers collègues le groupe de l'Union
centriste de votre a avec enthousiasme
nous comptons sur vous madame la
ministre pour vous en saisir avant que
ne se déclare les feux estivaux de 2023
auxquels nous n'échapperons
malheureusement pas vous serez en tout
cas entre les mains avec cette
proposition de loi les moyens pour mieux
les combattre et surtout les éviter ce
qui est notre priorité je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent la présidente
Nathalie de Lattre pour le Rassemblement
démocratique sociale européen
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues depuis l'ouverture de la
session au mois d'octobre dernier j'ai
déjà eu plusieurs fois l'occasion de
dire toutes l'émotion qu'on suscité les
grands feux de Gironde au cours de l'été
dernier mais aujourd'hui nos échanges
nourrissent une ambition plus grande au
regard de l'importance du texte qui nous
est proposé avant tout je voudrais
saluer le travail considérable d'Anne
Catherine Loisier Jean-Baptiste Pascal
Martin et Olivier Reitman nos collègues
se présentent devant nous avec une
triple casquette la première comme
auteur du très riche rapport sur les
feux de forêt et de végétation déposés
au mois d'août dernier la deuxième comme
hauteur de la proposition de loi que
nous avons à examiner aujourd'hui et la
troisième comme rapporteur pour notre
commission spéciale dont je veux dire
tout le sérieux des travaux et des
auditions qui ont été menées et
auxquelles j'ai activement participé
sans attendre de nouveaux incendies
dramatiques mais sans les oublier non
plus et à la lumière des fameux rétex
les retours d'expérience le Sénat c'est
donner les moyens de proposer une
réponse d'envergure pour preuve le texte
tel qu'il ressort des travaux de la
commission contre désormais plus de 40
actes articles et les ainsi l'ensemble
des problématiques liées à la prévention
du risque incendie sur nos territoires à
l'organisation de sa défense et à la
gestion des massifs forestiers postes
incendies pour reprendre une formule
chère à notre président Jean-Claude
requier nous sommes face à un texte
hétérogène mais non hétéroclite cet
hétérogénéité est un atout la lutte
contre l'embrasement se joue à de
nombreuses échelons en oubliés de mettre
en échec tous les autres
un échelon national d'abord dans votre
rapport du mois d'août madame et
Messieurs les rapporteurs vous avez
souligné très justement que les
politiques publiques de prévention et de
lutte contre les incendies de forêts et
de végétation se caractérisent par un
portage politique et administratif
complexe il est donc nécessaire de vrai
pour la mise en place en premier lieu
d'une stratégie nationale et
interministérielle comme le propose le
texte au fin de développer une approche
transversale qui permettra d'articuler à
tous les niveaux de l'État la prévention
incendie et la sécurité civile un
échelon local en second lieu qui doit
passer par un usage efficace des outils
de planification et de prévisions
lesquelles doivent mieux tenir compte
des risques incendies
je me réjouis en ce sens de l'adoption
par la Commission de mon amendement qui
vise à prévoir la consultation des
acteurs en charge de la défense des
forêts contre l'incendie pour
l'élaboration de documents d'urbanisme
des communes dont les bois et forêts
sont classés particulièrement exposés au
risque incendies il y a également un
échelon technique je pense ici à
l'action des sapeurs-pompiers que je
souhaite saluer à nouveau lors des
opérations de secours cette proposition
de loi est évidemment enrichie cette
dimension essentielle avec un volet de
disposition visant à renforcer
l'équipement de la lutte incendie
et j'aimerais ici saluer l'apport de
notre commission qui a adopté un
amendement que j'ai porté en commun avec
les rapporteurs et une autre collègue
gérondine qui vise à offrir une assise
juridique à la pratique des coupe
tactiques dans la continuité de ce qui a
été effectué dans l'urgence cet été en
Gironde et dans les Landes merci madame
et monsieur le rapporteur et enfin il
existe un échelon que l'on pourrait
qualifier de domestique car il faut
mobiliser les pouvoirs publics dans leur
ensemble nous devons aussi intégrer nos
concitoyens dans la réflexion tant du
point de vue de la prévention que dans
les gestes du quotidien le texte y
participe en proposant le financement
d'action et de communication afin de
prévenir notamment l'abandon de mégot ou
bien en consacrant l'interdiction de
fumer dans les forêts et boisées
classées à risque incendie j'y vois de
bonnes dispositions j'avais porté des
amendements relatifs à cette prévention
qui ont été déclarées et recevables car
de portée réglementaire j'en ferai
explication avant article tout à l'heure
mais surtout je saisirai pour évolution
du règlement les différents ministres
concernés ce texte est aussi majeur par
le renforcement du cadre juridique
relatif aux obligations légales de
débroussaillement les Old que beaucoup
d'élus locaux attendent et qui sont
essentiels dans la prévention cela étant
il reste encore de nombreuses pistes
pour avancer sur plusieurs points j'y
reviendrai lors de l'examen des
amendements pour beaucoup
issus de ce que j'ai pu vivre et
observer l'état dernier en Gironde en
conclusion le groupe RDS souhaite très
favorable à cette proposition de loi
d'autant qu'elle était largement
enrichie par l'adoption en commission
d'une série d'amendements soit intégrée
par les rapporteurs dans leurs
amendements rapporteurs que j'ai pu
présenter que j'ai pu porter avec le
soutien de mes collègues du groupe RDSE
est bien plus largement et en cela je
vous lis ici tous vous en remercier au
nom des girondines et des Girondins
merci
chers collègues la parole est à présent
à Monsieur Laurent Burgaud a pour les
républicains il a la parole
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la commission
spéciale madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
cette proposition de loi signa une
véritable prise de conscience en effet
nous l'avons tristement constaté l'été
dernier désormais c'est l'ensemble du
territoire national qui peut être frappé
par des incendies nous devons alors nous
y préparer comme nous devons en
parallèle lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
cette proposition de loi est donc très
attendue notamment dans mon département
du Gard où la commune de Bordeaux Zac
pour ne citer qu'elle a vu l'an dernier
si ça va hectares brûlé l'occasion de
saluer ici l'engagement de
sapeurs-pompiers qui ont eu à traiter
pas moins de 114 feux de forêt dans ceux
de hobés Générac ou encore Galar nous
devons pas nous y habituer nous ne
devons pas et d'ailleurs nous ne pouvons
pas nous le permettre comme la
parfaitement démontré le rapport
d'information de mes collègues et je
tiens à les remercier très
chaleureusement pour leur travail les
feux vont s'intensifier s'étendre
géographiquement comme dans le temps
avec des périodes sécheresse de plus en
plus longues enfin les terres agricoles
elles-mêmes seront de plus en plus
vulnérables
à travers le texte qui est examiné
aujourd'hui il s'agit de traduire dans
la loi certains propositions ne se
rapportentatoriales ce dont je me
réjouis en effet pour mettre rendu sur
place et avoir échangé avec élu et
membre du gardois je sais à quel point
le bon respect des obligations légales
débroussaillement dites au LD peut être
décisif plusieurs articles sont ainsi
destinés à mieux faire appliquer ces
obligations de débroussaillement
conditionnez la mutation d'un terrain
concernée par les Old au respect de ces
dernières est une bonne chose de même
qu'accroître les sanctions
administratives mais aussi pénales en
cas de non respect dans ce même esprit
l'article 11 qui rend la franchise
obligatoire dans les contrats
d'assurance en cas de non-respect des
eld a été enrichi pour punir pénalement
les attestations assurances faisant état
de fait matériellement inexacts
je réponds à part l'occasion de défendre
vraiment de bain qui vise à mieux
informer les acquéreurs de parcelles
concernées notamment lors de leur
passage devant le notaire trop de mers
regretta encore que leur administré
ignore l'existence même de cette
obligation
il sera également question de
l'indemnisation de ceux qui se
substituent à leurs voisins défaillants
l'article 13 de la plaisante proposition
de loi dispose que l'autorité
administrative compétente de l'État
adresse aux communes une carte d'Alea
permettant de cartographier à l'échelle
des communes concernées le risque
incendie de forêt de surface agricole et
de végétation il faut en effet plus de
dialogue entre les services de l'État et
les communes qui évidemment connaissent
bien mieux leur territoire madame le
ministre si vous pouvez écouter ça
serait mieux c'est d'autant plus
important que les cartes transmises sont
des prises de vue satellites avec leur
lot d'erreur qui convient d'affiner en
concertation avec les maires j'ai en
tête l'exemple de frissac où le
cimetière figuré en avait un feu très
élevé ou d'autres communes encore qui
ont du notifié certaines erreurs
manifestes d'où l'importance de nourrir
Madame le Ministre ce dialogue entre
service de l'État et élu territoriaux
pour toutes ces raisons et d'autres
encore qui sont évoqués par mes
collègues je voterai comme mon groupe
cette proposition de loi qui va dans le
bon sens comme d'ailleurs la loi
d'orientation de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui reconnaît
en matière de feu de forêt l'excellence
de la base sécurité civile de Nîmes qui
je l'espère deviendra bientôt une agence
européenne
enfin permettez-moi de rappeler et nous
sommes nombreux ici à le savoir que ce
sont quasiment toujours les communes
rurales petite dans leur démographie
mettez très grande par leur surface qui
doivent faire face à ces feux les élus
de ces communes n’attendent pas que
Paris leur dise quoi faire mais que des
moyens supplémentaires leur soient
alloués pour par exemple rénover leur
bonne incendie embaucher de gènes
surveillance durant l'été installé des
bâches à eau et même financés leurs
propres débroussaillement pour conclure
nous ne pouvons plus nous contenter de
déplorer les effets de nos chérissons
les causes nous devons un premier temps
nous adapter au réchauffement climatique
mais aussi accélérer notre transition
écologique notamment madame la ministre
en facilitant l'accès au fond vert à nos
communes rurales mes chers collègues
nous sommes désormais en 2023 nos forêts
brûlent et nous ne pouvons plus regarder
ailleurs je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant à Madame Vanina
Paoli Gaga pour le groupe des
indépendants
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous avons subi ça a
été dit une sécheresse estivale intense
même en grand test c'est contre intuitif
même dans mon département de l'Aube nous
avions eu un certain nombre d'hectares
150 en grandes S qui sont partis en
fumée plusieurs hectares dans la commune
de Mussy-sur-Seine vraiment à l'est du
Grand est
quasiment toutes nos régions ont été
touchées et plus personnellement plus
sensiblement vous en conviendrez un
arbre qui brûle c'est un peu de nous qui
s'en va
il nous faut donc agir agir parce que
l'été est passé est malheureusement
notre avenir nous vivons aussi une
stress hivernale historique nous ne
pourrons plus être surpris par le
déclenchement de feu en février cela a
été dit le manque de ressources en eau
les restrictions ne seront plus le
quotidien seulement des régions du Sud
et au mois d'août ce qui nous arrive
mais malheureusement plus l'exception
qui le rend extraordinaire cela devient
notre ordinaire
en octobre dernier lors de la niche
parlementaire de mon groupe Les
Indépendants j'ai présenté une
proposition de loi visant à mieux
valoriser certaines externalités
positives de la forêt
j'ai pu alors exprimer toute
l'importance de l'arbre dans nos
transitions qu'elle soit à la fois
écologique mais aussi économique et
culturelle la ressource bois et la
filière bois représente des perspectives
immenses dans la transformation de nos
modes de vie
nous devons aussi travailler à
multiplier les forêts pédagogiques ou
encore à classer nos arbres remarquables
qui sont aussi notre patrimoine
mon groupe est attaché à l'importance
vitale de la forêt et à la nécessité de
faire émerger prise de conscience et
impérative d'action la proposition loi
mais sénatorée qui répondait à une
attente forte des territoires est
aujourd'hui grâce à vous mes chers
collègues dans notre droit chaque
citoyen chaque entreprise peut s'en
saisir pour participer à la gestion
durable de sa forêt communale je dis
sans saisir peut s'en saisir mes doigts
sans saisir ce dispositif est l'alliance
de beaucoup de choses dans lesquelles je
crois et qui font la différence
l'association des efforts publics et
privés la vision d'une écologie libérale
une gestion durable qui allie écologie
économie et sociale et c'est dans ce
même esprit que je me félicite de
l'arrivée de cette proposition de loi
sur le risque incendie dont je félicite
l'auteur
ce texte marque insigne fort
d'engagement des sénateurs pour la
défense de la forêt je salue tous les
membres de la commission spéciale qui
ont eu à coeur de faire de ce texte la
réponse aux nombreuses problématiques
que nous rencontrons je tiens tout
particulièrement à souligner le travail
de nos rapporteurs à l'écoute et très
investi nos objectifs sont clairs tirer
les leçons des derniers mois rendre le
système de lutte plus efficace flexible
et agile sur nos territoires
inclure tous les acteurs y compris les
citoyens dans le rôle on l'a vu a été
majeure et la prise de conscience réelle
armé la forêt face aux risques incendie
afin qu'elle soit moins exposées
la gestion durable est équilibrée de la
forêt et la clé de sa résilience future
mais parce que la forêt est un lieu
extraordinaire les problématiques
auxquelles elle fait face le son tout
autant
les solutions apportées dans ce texte
ouvre la voie aux évolutions que nous
devons mettre en place d'abord de
manière générale inclure
systématiquement le risque incendie dans
les documents d'urbanisme et à cet égard
la gestion durable de la forêt parait du
bon sens permettre une évolution et donc
de la souplesse dans les documents et
stratégies les tout autant la prévention
et la base de l'adaptation quand il
s'agit de lutte contre le risque
incendie cette affirmation prend toute
sa force ensuite les bons financements
et la mise à disposition des moyens
seront cruciaux effectivement dans les
mois et années qui arrivent à ce titre
je vois la pérennisation du défi comme
une bonne nouvelle son encadrement me
semble pertinent les bonnes pratiques
sylvicales y sont encouragés elles
doivent être accompagnées faire en sorte
que chaque citoyen soit sensibilisé est
au cœur d'une défense efficace de notre
forêt certes les interdictions de fumer
en forêt à risque sont essentielles mais
bien au-delà afin de permettre aux
propriétaires de forêt de pouvoir mieux
gérer celle-ci et il leur ont donné les
moyens et crucial chacun sait la
complexité du morcellement et l'enjeu
que cela représente en termes de
capacité de gestion je veux saluer
particulièrement les agriculteurs et
leurs actions déterminantes cet été le
rôle des champs d'agriculture est majeur
dans la conception de la lutte contre
les incendies de forêts les
facilitations dans l'emploi des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires cela a été
dit sujet au combien important au Sénat
vont évidemment dans le bon sens
c'est pourquoi mes chers collègues même
s'il nous reste encore beaucoup pas
faire le groupe Les Indépendants votera
favorablement pour ce texte il est
espéré à la fois comme impulsion et
première fondation d'une stratégie de
préservation de la forêt face aux
incendies mieux adaptés à nos
territoires et plus flexibles je vous
remercie
chers républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues
sans commune point de lutte contre les
incendies dans l'Aude soumis depuis des
décennies aux incendies ravageurs nous
savons que les communes sont
essentielles elles créent et
entretiennent les équipements
indispensables aux pompiers dans la
lutte contre les feux pistes citerne
zone d'appui et vous le savez ce sont
des investissements qui pèsent
lourdement sur les finances communales
dans notre région
Occitanie les communes n'ont d'ailleurs
pas attendu les ordres venus d'en haut
pour investir dans la prévention et les
moyens de lutte et ce depuis plus d'un
demi-siècle
les communes sont indispensables avec
leur groupement et le langage des
budgets de plus en plus conséquents dans
la mise en oeuvre des politiques de
défense des forêts contre les incendies
à travers notamment le financement des
services des départementaux d'incendie
et de secours les communes sont
primordiales les maires agissent dans le
cadre du pouvoir de police que leur a
délégué l'Etat ils sont en pleine
responsabilité sur ces sujets et en sont
d'ailleurs pénalement responsables les
obligations légales de débroussaillement
old figurent en bonne place des
responsabilités qu'assument les mères
alors face à ce constat comment être à
la hauteur déjà en associant pleinement
les élus des communes et des communes
forestières à la définition des
politiques de prévention et de lutte
contre l'incendie ensuite en simplifiant
en soutenant financièrement les communes
forestières et leurs élus pour améliorer
les règles afin de gagner en efficacité
face au feu
enfin un adaptant les dispositifs aux
enjeux contemporains mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi qui nous amène ici
cet après-midi et le fruit d'un travail
important qu'il convient de saluer oui
il était urgent d'élargir la stratégie
nationale de prévention et de lutte
contre les incendies en intangrant la
prévention et la lutte dans les
documents d'urbanisme mais également
dans les différentes missions des
opérateurs de l'État oui il faut
accompagner les particuliers et le monde
agricole dans le respect et la mise en
oeuvre de leurs où elles le D mais je me
permettrai de souligner plusieurs
écueils ma collègue Laurent se arrivait
la souligner l'État doit être à la
hauteur des enjeux financiers de plus
nous estimons qu'il est important et de
véritablement mettre les élus des
communes forestières au cœur des
dispositifs parce qu'ils sont
incontournables et constituent le pivot
des politiques de prévention et de lutte
contre les incendies à ce titre ils
doivent être pleinement acteurs de leur
définition les amendements que nous
portons avec le groupe socialiste
illustre cette volonté dans un souci de
simplification et d'efficacité des
dispositifs nous avons également
travaillé tout au long du titre 2 à la
création d'un diagnostic de l'obligation
légale de débroussaillement sur le
modèle du diagnostic de performance
énergétique un tel diagnostic d'une part
en forcerait la réalisation des old
d'autre part serait une garantie forte
dans les diverses démarches
administratives auprès des assureurs
mais également des notaires en cas de
mutation de terrain si vous en
conviendrez une garantie plus
satisfaisante qu'une simple attestation
sur l'honneur comme le prévoit l'article
11 enfin nous pensons que la
mobilisation contre le risque incendie
doit concerner l'ensemble des acteurs de
la société
y compris les plus jeunes nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir sur l'ensemble de
ces éléments au cours de l'examen de ce
texte je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Madame Anne Ventalon pour
les républicains
[Applaudissements]
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues des incendies dévoraient
le ciel aux quatre coins de l'horizon
les nuits n'étaient plus noires mais
rouge ces mots
apocalyptiques pardon de René Barjavel
tiré de son roman ravage
décrivent-ils le futur de nos campagnes
avec leur 2240 hectares brûlés en 2022
les ardéchois seraient bien tentés de
répondre oui d'autant plus que la
sécheresse hivernale actuelle laisse
présager de nouveaux records d'incendie
baisserons-nous les bras pour autant non
l'intensification des feux de forêt
n'est pas une fatalité et le travail
méticuleux des auteurs et rapporteurs de
cette proposition de loi redonne la
volonté et l'espoir à ceux qui
combattent le feu à commencer par nos
pompiers
dans cette lutte ils ne sont pas seuls
et je veux d'abord souligner le rôle
fondamental des collectivités
territoriales les plans de prévention
des risques d'incendie de forêt
constituent un bon outil et je soutiens
la volonté d'encourager les
collectivités à se regrouper selon une
logique de massif en effet le feu ne
s'arrête pas aux frontières communales
je salue également la création d'une
délégation à la protection de la forêt
inspirée de la structure associant déjà
les départements méditerranéens ainsi
que la Drôme et l'Ardèche et dont je
témoigne de l'utilité nous devons à tous
les niveaux faciliter l'action de ceux
qui combattent le feu en première ligne
les pompiers de nos 10 d'abord comme le
préconise dont rapporteurs en faisant
respecter beaucoup plus strictement les
obligations légales de débroussaillement
c'est un point crucial car le défaut de
débroussaillage génère des feux en zone
habitée qui aurait dû être évité en cela
il concentre nos pompiers et les
détournent de la stratégie générale de
lutte contre le cynisme de même pour les
dispositions permettant d'accroître la
résistance des bâtiments aux incendies
de forêt on peut d'ailleurs s'inspirer à
ce titre des servitudes instaurées dans
le cadre des installations classées pour
la protection de l'environnement en
plantant une végétation qui fait tampon
je pense notamment aux cultures faisant
office de coupe-feu comme les eaux
livrées ou les vignes entretenues dans
la même logique le réaménagement
effectué à la suite d'un incendie de
forêt et primordial il s'agit non
seulement de réhabiliter les espaces
détruits mais également de les aménager
de telle sorte qu'un futur feu verra ses
effets à moindry il faut enfin parler à
l'apparition d'autres risques comme les
glissements de terrain survenant à cause
de la perte du couvert végétal
je veux rappeler ici la force menante
contre les incendies ce sont les 10 à ce
sujet je me félicite de l'opiniâtreté de
nous rapporteurs qui ont réintroduit les
dispositions déjà promues par le Sénat
la réduction des cotisations patronales
pour les employeurs des pompiers
volontaires de même que la suppression
de la TICPE pour les 10
dans leur lutte contre des feux
dévorants extrêmement violents comment
imaginer que nos services de secours
puissent être empêchés ici par une
pénurie de matériel là par un problème
de personnel ou de formation sans appui
financier plus prononcé de l'État leur
engagement sera difficilement
supportable et là dessus l'été 2022 nous
offre la plus dramatique illustration
avec des 10 à la limite de la rupture
une politique publique de lutte contre
les incendies et extrêmement coûteuses
et concernent autant l'État les
collectivités les agriculteurs les
services de secours et les particuliers
nous savons que les décennies à venir
seront plus chaudes les feuilles seront
plus fréquents et sur des périodes de
l'année plus étendues anticipons madame
la ministre lançant une stratégie sur le
long terme avec des plans de financement
pluriannuels
enfin je tenais pour conclure à saluer
et encourager les réserves citoyennes de
sécurité civile comme celles récemment
créée à Lagorce dans mon département de
l'Ardèche elles ont pour mission d'agir
en amont de patrouiller d'aider les
pompiers en accompagnant les sondages du
feu et en complétant les efforts
importants des agriculteurs elles
permettent ainsi aux citoyens de
s'engager eux-mêmes dans la défense de
leur envie dans leur environnement
montrant ainsi que les ravages ne sont
pas inéluctables je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant la parole est à Madame
Valérie Boyer pour les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame le Ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues malheureusement
l'année 2022 restera comme une des plus
dévastatrices sur le front des feux de
forêt à l'échelle mondiale tant en
termes de surface brûlée que des
missions de carbone plus de 785 000
hectares sont partis en fumée du premier
janvier au 19 novembre c'est plus du
double de la moyenne d'un peu plus de
317 000 hectares entre 2006 et 2021 ces
incendies ont entraîné des émissions
totales de carbone pour 2022 estimé à 9
mégatonnes comparativement à une moyenne
de 6,75 mégatonnes en 2003-2021 et notre
pays n'a pas été épargné en 2022 nous
l'avons tous dit Gironde landrome
Aveyron Lozère mais aussi Bretagne
Maine-et-Loire Jura et bien sûr
Bouches-du-Rhône en tout ce sont 256
départs de feu et même si les drames
humains sont heureusement rares se sont
temps de vie brisés et de catastrophes
écologiques en 2022 ce sont 2500 départs
de feu dans les Bouches-du-Rhône c'est
l'un des trois départements soumis au
plus fort risque d'incendie de forêt sur
la région méditerranéen et permettez-moi
mes chers collègues de saluer le sang
froid de l'ensemble des mers qui font
face chaque année à des incendies bien
souvent criminels je me souviens du feu
de la Montagnette l'été dernier dans le
nord du département par exemple et des
incendies qui ont ravagé les calanques à
plusieurs reprises
il y a plusieurs années à Marseille
aussi je partage la colère de ces mères
à l'image du maire de Barbentane mais
ils sont nombreux Christophe Daudet
durement touché par les feux cet été et
qui dénoncent le manque de moyens c'est
la raison pour laquelle je remercie
vraiment le Sénat d'avoir mis ce texte
de bon sens et de proximité à l'ordre du
jour de notre assemblée ce qui traduit
le demande des élus locaux et de nos
citoyens dans ce contexte je veux
remercier également les rapporteurs et
les auteurs de ce texte qui vise à
traduire les recommandations
législatives du rapport d'information
adopté ici en août dernier feu de forêt
et de végétation prévenir l'embrasement
nos collègues jean-bacit Anne-Catherine
Loisier Patrick Martin et Olivier
Reitmans ont fait un travail remarquable
en nous présentant aujourd'hui un test
qui comprend 38 mesures aussi nous ne
réussissons pas la lutte contre les
incendies sans sensibiliser la
population 9 feux sur 10 sont d'origine
humaine et cette sur 10 serait liée à
l'imprudence humaine
aussi toute utilisation du feu peut
alors être une source de départ
d'incendie de forêt c'est pour cela
qu'une attitude citoyenne et la
vigilance de chacun sont impératives
l'information et la sensibilisation sont
indispensables et je voudrais revenir
sur quelques points l'article 30 prévoit
de s'appuyer sur la filière de
responsabilité élargie du producteur
rept pour financer les actions de
communication afin de prévenir l'abandon
de mégot notamment dans les territoire
réputés particulièrement exposés au
risque d'incendie et dans les bois et
forêts classés à risque d'incendie enfin
nous ne réussirons pas sans sanction et
c'est pourquoi l'article 31 a pour objet
de consacrer au niveau législatif
l'interdiction de fumer dans un bois une
forêt classée à risque d'incendie enfin
mes chers collègues je ne pouvais
prendre la parole aujourd'hui sans
rendre un hommage appuyé à l'ensemble
des pompiers avec bien sûr dans un
certain un certain opinisme que j'assume
je veux saluer l'engagement des marins
de pompiers de Marseille et du 10 des
Bouches-du-Rhône est-il plus noble
mission et plus belle mission que celle
consiste à risquer sa vie pour en sauver
d'autres s'il est une famille
unanimement aimée et respectée qui force
l'admiration de tous en France c'est
bien celle que forment les
sapeurs-pompiers et les marins-pompiers
et je crois qu'uneanimement nous pouvons
leur dire merci et ce texte consacre une
partie importante du titre 7 article 32
à 34 en prévoyant d'équiper la lutte
incendie à hauteur du risque avec trois
mesures que je veux vous citer exonérer
de la tipc les carburants utilisés par
les véhicules opérationnels des
surveillance des 10 exonéré de malus
écologique tout véhicule affecté aux
besoins de la protection civile et des
services de lutte contre les incendies
et une mesure phare instaurer une
réduction de cotisations patronale pour
les entreprises administration en
contrepartie de la disponibilité de
leurs employés et agents exerçant en
tant que sapeur-pompiers volontaire
aussi je le dis à nos pompiers qui
suivent ces débats les Français savent
tout ce que tout ce que vous faites tout
ce que votre mission représente
d'engagement et de sacrifices ils savent
que vous la remplissez avec tout votre
cœur toute votre intelligence et votre
talent soyez en remercier parce que
c'est vous qui préservez nos vies notre
patrimoine et nos paysages je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
notre discussion générale est un cyclose
et nous passons à discussion du texte de
la commission sur l'article premier nous
avons en première escrime monsieur
Menonville qui a la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues alors que
notre pays a été confronté l'été dernier
à des feux de forêt d'une intensité
rarement égalée je me félicite que notre
assemblée se saisisse de cette
problématique et je tiens à saluer le
travail donc des auteurs le texte que
nous étudions aujourd'hui a pour
ambition première d'adapter les outils
de lutte et de prévention au nouveau
défi de changement climatique et plus
particulièrement à la vulnérabilité
grandissante des massifs forestiers
ce risque s'étend aujourd'hui à des
territoires jusqu'à lors épargnés je
voudrais évoquer le cas particulier de
mon département de la Meuse et de la
zone rouge elle représente 12000
hectares du champ de bataille de Verdun
où le sol est l'une des et d'une
nature toute particulière en effet elle
renferme nombre de munitions et d'obus
qui présentent encore de grandes
dangerosités sur ces sols le risque
d'incendie est particulièrement prégnant
il a d'ailleurs été renforcé par les
attaques de scolyte et les dépérissement
dans cette forêt composé en partie de
résin